okay so when I was really young I loved
playing video games and I kind of
noticed that when you play video games
you have to be really really focused so
if you're playing me mario kart on the
Nintendo 64 so you're driving along and
of course there's a Koopa waiting to hit
you but if you blink or you say oh I
need to get something to eat or I need
some chips so you put your controller
down and when the Koopa smashes into so
you diet with life and of course you get
you in video games you have plenty of
lives so it's okay but in box when
you're performing you don't have that
kind of a privilege so you have to stay
really focus through the whole thing and
you can't stop
I think that was when I was five or six
I think six I went to this piano
competition in Oakland and my from was
playing a piano concerto with my older
piano teacher and I think that was the
first time I ever played in public which
is kind of interesting because it wasn't
actually performance it was a
competition
I mean of course I get nervous so I just
try to focus on the music itself I try
not to think about anything besides the
music so usually before I walk on stage
I'm just kind of playing the piece over
to myself again and again and walking
through some of the spots where I know I
need to be focused on what kind of a
sound or character I'm producing
often in bak if you make a big mistake
it's really difficult to find your way
back so it's almost necessary to just
stop and start over again which I've
done that quite a few times but if just
little mistakes like if you miss a
couple of notes I try to forget about
that section and skip to maybe a few
bars forward so that a few bars forward
I know that I can keep playing and it
will be fine